the spread of fake news i'm delighted
that we have the members of the libyan
anger committees and a special welcome
to the chair of the inga committee mr
rafael glooksman and
we've been since the setup of the
inga committee which i remember we've
had great cooperation and let me
mr glicksman i'd like to give you the
floor
thank you chair thank you dear sabine
yes our cooperation has been working
beautifully and i'd like to express
thanks to you
for having taken this initiative and
working with the inga committee to
get this meeting going and i think it's
something fundamental this is a really a
key moment of time this is a decisive
moment
when it comes to the war of information
when it comes to fighting propaganda and
disinformation on the part of russian
networks uh
on the as of the 24th of february what
there's been the aggression on
ukraine by russia but that this isn't
the beginning of their disinformation
campaigns in europe it's been going on
for quite some time now and over the
past 18 months we've been looking into
this who are the players what are the
impacts and
we've drawn up a report and it's rather
straightforward and clear and addresses
the issue of independent journalism and
there's an effort that has to be made in
europe at present to see to it that our
democracies go on benefiting from
independent journalism
investigative uh journalism quality
journalism and that to do that we have
to protect uh journalists legally
economically and it's also
facing the fact that journalism
independent journalism and media
pluralism has to be
seen as more than just
a matter of a market
there's
more to it than that and then what is
the definition of what a media is and
when it comes to what we've seen now
over the past few years is the use
of propaganda tools and they give that
are given the name
uh media but
uh
they're not media it's uh poutine i mean
we've heard about sputnik and rt
uh that hit the headlines and there's a
need now to define what protections are
required for media for journalists and
what is a medium
so that it won't just be
a propaganda tool at the service of a
regime that triggers a war with ukraine
but that also undermines our principles
and our interests and there's a
consultation uh that uh we have seen
carried out from june uh to march and
we've come up with the european media
freedom act uh that's in the works and
it would be good to hear
what you have to say about these
consultations and the idea of this emfa
and then the hopes when it comes to what
the public authorities can do to
preserve the possibility to having high
quality independent journalism in our
countries the information war is not
restricted to the borders of the eu or
to russia at present for instance
when it comes to
uh the
um cereals
and famine uh there are two of russia is
a foot with disinformation and we in
europe have the advantage in our
societies
to uh cover the war in uh ukraine and
uh the russian propaganda has not
managed to undermine our effectiveness
and elsewhere in the world uh
for instance in africa they had to have
access to uh our media so we have to
think together what we can do
as public authorities in europe to help
journalism and to
face up to this major offensive on the
part of a regime that not only shuts
down independent media in russia but
plans to undermine all
connections with
the truth elsewhere in the world so i'm
dead keen on hearing what our guests
have to say about these fundamental
issues and thank you for having invited
me along
thank you very much uh
the
uh
kremlin's war against the
ukraine against ukraine is also war
against uh information
and
it's undermining of course a journalism
everywhere it treads when it comes to
this broad
invasion the russian armed forces
targeted journalists intentionally and
sought to destroy
broadcasting infrastructure and over and
beyond that
the russian citizens are deprived of any
information about the operations taking
place in
ukraine
and the
legal framework has been tightened up
there's no free speech anymore access to
facebook and major platforms have been
blocked and whoever
allegedly
spreads
false information can end up behind bars
for 15 years and even holding up an
empty poster was already grounds for
arrest because one
could have written something on it then
that would not have been approved you
could see
how paranoid they are now in russia and
also the strategy to
see to it that citizens are only fed
information that comes from the state
the shortage of free media and given the
massive suppression of the political
opposition has dreadful consequences and
as a result of that a lot of them were
journalists who
were working independently and freely
but they now
they and activists and
civil organizations uh members are
fleeing russia and is looking for asylum
in
the eu or neighboring countries to try
there to go on and report
and to see that information flow into
russia in
dependent information about uh the war
in ukraine in particular now against
that backdrop our exchange of
our discussion today rather will be very
interesting it will give us an overview
of what's up in russia and ukraine but
over and beyond that the uh general
picture as to
what's up in terms of
undermining the media and
uh democracy is
based on the need for
free media and journalism i would now
like to welcome our guest speakers most
warmly first of all mr oliver manikuli
he is the director
of the europe international press
institute ipi
we have miss uh renata shirda she's the
director of the european association of
journalists she's online we have mr john
paul martos
uh
journalist professor for international
journalism at the uh ucl and he's the
editorial coordinator of the council of
europe report defending press freedom of
times detention and conflict 2022
we have missed julie mayo zach the
head of the brussels office of reporters
without borders and i'd
like to very warmly welcomed three brave
uh journalists from russia miss
katharina abramova she's the director
for communication at medusa an
independent online platform uh dennis
konbeyevsky he's in charge of
cooperative operations at medusa as well
as dennis cardiff as a journalist from
tv reign which until uh 20 well it was
shut down in march 202 march 2022 i.e of
this year and now he is active in paris
at radio falls and then there's the
commission representatives with malcolm
give a special welcome to first of all
mr giuseppe i'm amanda director for
media and policy uh from dg connect i
don't know if he's online he'll be
tuning up later on then from the eeas mr
yan la tod information and
communications officer and expert for
strategic communication and we begin now
our
exchange of views
well
let me begin by giving the floor
two
miss uh another shoulder you have the
floor for five minutes
okay good morning i thought it was
oliver money curl never mind
uh
thank you very much
to both of you opportunity given to
discuss with bold cult liber and injure
the issues
indeed at the heart of the european
federation of journalists in these
difficult times on media freedom and
protection of journalists
i'm still in izmir so sorry for not
being there with you where we just
finished our general meeting with 49
organizations from 32 countries present
including from the ukraine and russia
adopting many resolutions including on
safety media freedom the urgent need for
support for local journalism including
local journalism in the ukraine
in 22 alone 13 journalists in europe
lost their life while on duty 12 of them
while reporting the war
12 journalists in now four months for
the people's right to know
journalism has become a dangerous and
very precarious mission throughout
europe and not only for war reporters
jean-paul martos will talk about the
increased alerts regarding attacks
against journalists be it physical or
online
when we discuss media freedom and
protection of journalist issues we have
to look at it from a holistic and
approach and that's why i will refer to
our ambitions for the european media
freedom act at the beginning at the end
our colleagues in turkey told us that 90
of the media market is captured that
means controlled by politicians and
business
unfortunately this is not unique to
turkey the problem of media captures is
a serious one we have within the
european union and not only in hungary
and poland
my fellow speaker of oliver monica will
outline these threats in detail
this all is aggravated by recent moves
by many governments to completely
silence the media by adopting dangerous
so-called laws on disinformation the
recent example from russia and turkey
show this but we have others from
hungary and greece for example
such a bill where the definition of
disinformation is left so vague
puts journalists at risk of criminal
action for posting information that the
government disagrees with
this information is an important issues
and needs to be combated but not at the
price of restricting journalists rights
and the public's right of freedom of
expression you will discuss this in the
second panel but i want to stress that
the efj is against censoring or banning
we call on the eu policy makers to
strengthen self-regulation and
co-regulation to continue projects like
the one the efj is leading on media
councils in the digital world and to
strengthen and protect independent
journalism
how can you build a sustainable business
model
when journalists face fear of being
attacked judicially prosecuted and
self-censored themselves how can you
build trust and fight this information
when you work under precarious
conditions when your employer does not
invest in training or digital safety or
investigative tools or artificial
intelligence and cut and paste
journalism click bait becomes the norm
in an ever more fragile news industry
which is as we all know competing with
the logics of social media and its
attention-based economy
we talk about market failure in
journalism and the challenge of
sustainable funding of media viability
in particular at local level
the center for press and media freedom
in in florence with a special covet 19
edition last year showed that on media
viability 10 countries within the eu
scored a high risk and let me quote
employment and salary trends highlight a
high risk for the economic safety of
journalists despite the surge in demand
for information and trusted sources
in particular the growing number of ever
more precarious freelance journalists
underline this high risk
so what do we need to do also with
regard as i just said and as mr gripsman
said regarding the upcoming european
media freedom act
let me just summarize giving you four
points which are important in my mind
first we need to re-establish the notion
of journalism as a public good
and for that we need support from many
stakeholders including the european
parliament and i'm grateful for your
welcoming support this morning
it needs protecting in its own right it
needs support to public private and
philanthropic funding of course always
at arm's length it also needs social
protection in particular for freelancers
we need to fight media capture through
full transparency of ownership and
allocation of state aid
and yes we do need to discuss what kind
of media we wish to protect
self-regulation as i said and guarantees
of right of freedom of expression and
media freedom are crucial today
on safety we need to convince
governments of the priority of
protecting journalists and enabling them
to do their work by creating a safe
environment the eu safety recommendation
adopted last year gives an excellent
framework but it needs to be implemented
at national level and for that as we all
know political will is so important this
includes the importance of sufficient
funding to ensure that journalists and
fixers working in war zones have the
necessary equipment and utmost
protection
media organizations have a duty of care
sending their stuff and freelancers to
war zones
we are working with a coalition of press
freedom digital rights and journalist
groups to make sure the eu will deliver
and adopt a strong hopefully regulation
a strong european media freedom act
reflecting such a holistic approach
thank you very much
thank you very much
the next speaker is oliver monet curly
hello thank you thank you very much for
inviting me and um i just apologize for
not being with you today in in the uh in
the parliament unfortunately i have a
meeting at 10 o'clock with the that
coalition of media freedom and uh
freedom expression groups that renata
just referred to as um immediately
afterwards at 10 o'clock where we are
trying to define and agree our positions
on on on the media freedom act um let me
just just start by saying that that ipi
international press institute we've been
we have a a media violations tracker uh
monitoring the situation the front line
the information war on the front line of
ukraine and the casualties today
statistics read some
437 different types of media freedom
alerts or violations in ukraine russia
belarus etc since since 24th of february
this includes the 12
kill journalists 82 verbal online and
physical attacks 90 arrests or charges
against journalists some
167 incidents of censorship three new
laws in in in russia
and six restrictions on access to
information that is not a totally
comprehensive overview but it gives you
a gives you an extent of the of the
intensity of the information warfare
that is taking place as part of the
actual physical conflict um
i'd also like to sort of quote dimitri
maraviev who's the the editor of nevada
gazetta on world press freedom day when
he addressed the event in the balzar him
here in brussels
on the 3rd of may when he asked the
question about how is it that the future
of the entire world lies in the hands
of one man
and he put this down to the death
of german independent journalism
in russia and that is what set the stage
for allowing enabling him to be
in this position
um
the horrors of war
i think have exposed just how vulnerable
our democracies are
and yet here in europe we're seeing how
the same mechanisms and processes used
in russia and turkey as renata has
referred to
to gain control over media spaces are
being adapted perfected and employed
here in member states in the european
union and it's happening under our noses
and in many ways we've been complicit
and
complicit in this and providing consent
because by turning a blind eye the eu
has been giving consent to the to this
process here
democracy dies when good people do
nothing
in april fidez won another
landslide victory in hungary in an
election campaign with a public
broadcaster i used to turn public ball
cover quite quite broadly though i
should say the state propaganda arm
afforded the opposition leading
candidate five minutes only to give his
uh position in the entire
election campaign
this is neither a free nor fair election
when that takes place the very
fundamentals of the values of our
european democracy are at risk the last
decade has seen independent media sector
gutted by fidez that has misused the
powers and the finances of the state to
ensure the vast majority of media in the
hands of its inner circle
they filled the media regulator with
fidez loyalists to silence independent
voices from the airwaves and reduce the
independent media sector to effectively
a niche interest
as as renata mentioned earlier we call
this process
media capture
and its success
is being closely replicated we've seen
that in poland we've seen that in
bulgaria
czech republic and obviously slovenia
all of these have suffered variations
along the same theme
and in slovenia's case it wasn't just
replicated it was exported it was
exported through the use of hungarian
capital
purchasing and investing in media
aligned with fidesz's ideological ally
the sds
now slovenia's election and the czech
election uh a few months early were of
course a rebuke to the illiberal
political model and reforming
governments have an opportunity and a
duty to make good on their promises of
reform
but the threat has not gone away and
they cannot do it alone
if there is something positive to have
emerged from this war then that it then
it is that it is concentrating minds and
refocusing efforts to protect our
democratic spaces from the disaster that
has befallen russia's
when i ask editors in eastern europe
what the most important thing that eu
can do
to stop media capture
their first reply
is to stop funding it the eu must do
that
but it can also do much more we're very
pleased that finally the commission
over the last couple of years has taken
this issue started to take this issue
with the seriousness that it deserves
and have drafted or in the process of
drafting the european medium media
freedom act and this provides a unique
opportunity to develop the tools rules
and standards to confront the drivers of
media capture
renato is already
highlighted some of the some of the
principles that that we share um in
terms of wanting to see in the media
freedom act transparency is probably the
most important one transparency of media
ownership and of financial relations
between the state and media actors
throwing the light onto the true owners
and the true beneficiaries of media and
of relations with the government is the
most essential step to addressing the
problem
secondly setting tight rules for state
funding of media to ensure it cannot be
politicized and abused to create
compliant a compliant media sector
the next step being a cheerleading
propaganda sector is vital renatas
refers to the abuse of state advertising
rules of public subsidies etc and the
need for having arms length independent
funding mechanisms with clear criteria
that awards quality public interest
journalism over clientelism
importantly and i know that there are
some there are some concerns about the
impact on the media economy of
regulation um out there but we believe
that's that such an act would help
reduce or remove
the barriers to the media market that
currently exists in media captured
states
um
clientless media have an unfair
advantage because of their subsidies and
their relationships with the state which
prevent
investments into media by lowering those
barriers we believe that this will give
a massive boost to the europe's media
economy as a whole
thirdly we think that media there should
be media pluralism tests for media
mergers and other instruments to monitor
and measure the impact of media
pluralism across europe
fourthly we support
any initiative that can help improve and
strengthen the independence of media
regulators and increase the standards
thereof that's an extremely complex
issue but anything that emfa can do to
that would be
welcome and finally
funding innovation and cri and
creativity in the market to ensure a
vibrant media economy is essential
without a vibrant profitable media
economy
um the cam that there will be no media
pluralism
um
lastly um
renault also referred to this but the
the the bounty of arty and sputnik
obviously calls a big a big debate and
uh many of us
argued and disagreed on whether the ban
should have taken place and how it took
place etc
most importantly though it's opened up a
debate a really
important debate about how we protect
our democracies
from
from investments from countries that are
fundamentally opposed and hostile to our
democratic values and i welcome that
debate thank you very much
thank you very much and now the last
speaker in our first panel is jean-paul
martou
i will give the floor to
mr martou please press the speak button
i'm the only person who's actually here
in the room
it's a pleasure to be here
i haven't been here for two years i
coordinate
the work of the
defending press freedom in times of
tension and conflict work at the coe
we bring together the ipi
journalists without borders and so on so
we draw on the alerts that have been
raised
and
we
take stock of what's happening in the
council of europe countries of course
russia has been suspended after its
invasion of ukraine
so
we look at
what's happened to journalists if it
could include attacks and many other
categories of attacks against
journalists
so this year
the
situation in ukraine and the russian
invasion has really upended everything
the consequences on press freedom
are massive
the first
is
that if you're a war correspondent in
ukraine you're at massive risk they're
the ones who are
telling us about the war this reminds us
of other wars that we have forgotten
wars
a war from the 90s the
war in the balkans where around 150
journalists were killed
already
a few dozen journalists have died
as we've heard from
reporters without borders
and there have been complaints submitted
to the international criminal court by
journalists stating that there is
there are war crimes being committed so
that's the situation
then there is also repression and
censorship of independent journalists in
russia that is the end of a long process
and
the platform
has
enumerated and chronicled the worsening
of the situation in russia
over recent years
we've
seen that
journalists have been labeled as
foreign agents
and then we've also got memorial which
is
an important uh source of information
for
journalists
now the questions we're asking ourselves
are key ones are evident how do we
protect journalists if they're covering
the war in ukraine how do we inform
people about what's happening in russia
because there's a real blockage
russia
would like to impose its so-called
splinternet
it wants to have its own internet
sovereignty and
protect its citizens from any harmful
outside information from outside its
borders
so there's really a lot at stake these
are complicated matters so how do we
bypass russian censorship when we have
to be aware of the fact that
the
russian state
is able to crack down on vpns
and deals with
foreign media outlets abroad
the bbc has relaunched its uh russian
language
radio but
that's been jammed
so how do we help russian journalists
who are under
constant pressure from the state how do
we help those russian journalists who
have fled they often find it difficult
to get a visa and to set up shop in new
countries
uh in in the countries where they're
being welcomed so all of that is very
important
and there's a rather divisive element i
mean i am the coordinator but there is a
split in the journalistic profession
there's the issue of whether rt should
be banned or not
what is very clear in our report
is that russia has relays
in
his antenna in various member states so
this is not just a geopolitical
dimension here there's an ideological
dimension if you allow me to
compare basically
it's been 50 years since watergate why
am i talking about watergate today in
the european parliament when we should
be talking about ukraine well the two
journalists that were behind watergate
they've published an introduction
to their new
book
shout out to the president they compare
trump and nixon in that book
they say nixon abused power
but he never called american democracy
into question but
trump seditiously
has called into question the very basis
of democracy that's what's happening in
russia today as well but also in various
other european countries there are
states and governments and political
parties who are calling
liberal democracy into question and
the bedrock on which the eu is based
that's a true danger
i think that some of my colleagues
will mention the measures that have been
adopted by governments so taking control
of the media and regulators it's what
they've been doing
so
i'll just
take 30 seconds to talk about the rest
of the report
there is a lot more violence against
journalists including more physical
violence
last year there were 82 physical attacks
against journalists that's a 51 increase
on the previous year 2020 there's an
exponential rise
in online harassment including in
particular against female journalists of
course that affects journalism and
journalism practices there's also
targeted
action by the organized crime sector
europol in its range 21 report pointed
out that there is a growing danger
against investigative journalists
by organized criminal gangs
then there's the issue of
how
states respond to the alerts that have
been raised by the platform
only 35
of the alerts were reacted to
and
very few of the responses
were then actually considered
satisfactory by members of the platform
i think renato schroeder outlined the
current situation which is that things
are more flat fragile insecure
there's greater precariousness that's
not just due to the economic model of
course the economic model is an
important issue
but there's true hostility
against journalists
which
is fed by various organizations who
think that the press isn't important in
maintaining democracy
all of this is exacerbated by the fact
that some
high level
politicians denigrate journalists which
opens the door to violence against
journalists
i'll stop there
but if you have questions i'll hopefully
be able to react
thank you very much
we have reached the end of the first
panel
now i'd like to open the q a
miss ramona victoria
strougario is the first speaker
she is the probable libre reporter
for the media freedom act
in the coming months i'm sure we'll be
working hard together she'll be working
hard with the two committees mr cario
thank you thank you very much chair i
was pressing the voting button because
i'm coming from a vote in libre which
turned very complicated and i kept you
know the
the habit of doing in the other
committee um
thank you for this and thank you for the
opportunity uh to take the floor uh in
this exchange of views
and
i i am
actually
still not
happy with all what we do although we've
done a lot but there's plenty of space
uh more space to do related to media
freedom and and to the protection of
journalists
and i know that this this has been an
ongoing uh debate in this house we've
been asking for it for years the
commission is making efforts but
some somehow um i think we are still far
and there are ways to improve things i'm
um happy to see that the organizations
for the protection of journalists are
more and more involved in the process
because they know better uh how to do it
and they do have the experience uh on on
the ground as well and i truly hope that
we will also listen more and more to
their voices when we take decisions
related to the safety of the journalists
and to uh how to better protect their
work and their fight for the truth
because in the end they are the
guardians of democracies and they are
those who make sure that we continue to
live in in three worlds
um
related to ukraine and the war we all
know that 12 journalists have been
killed in this war while exercising
their job
uh
and uh these killings must be recognized
as war crimes but it is not only about
these 12 people it is about hundreds of
attacks only in ukraine uh to media
freedom is is about bombing radio and tv
stations
uh and
is about plenty of this information
about uh threats and about
all these uh activities that
we see not only in a war but everywhere
in hybrid worlds as well
um a massively uh um
done by by propaganda uh which are
killing basically democracy and truth
every day
uh
journalists reporting now from the front
line need our support more than ever and
one of the first things things that i
asked and we asked through the media
working group
was
for the member states and for this house
to support sending equipment protection
equipment to journalists which were uh
in ukraine and and uh basic things that
they needed and i we knew that
organizations and and civil society were
organizing themselves to send this
equipment but we didn't see
um
maybe the same instinct uh coming from
from
member states or or being an organized
decision you know that reflex of
defending media workers in the field uh
as as they immediately went there or
those ukrainian ones and maybe this
exercise we should also do uh more often
the
questions that i have and that i would
like to to address
are of course uh
also
matters of reflection uh
i i would like to know um about
how your organizations have been in
support
to the journalists from the front line
how can we support
your activity and how can we make sure
those necessary supplies
make it to them
do you know and if yes how do you
monitor the evolution of the situation
of those journalists on the front
do you have a better picture of their
immediate needs
how can we be of any help in increasing
the visibility of these needs and
bringing them into the attention of
decision makers
in the context of safeguarding media
freedom and protecting journalists we
should not forget those russian
independent journalists who are
currently under heavy attack back in
their home country many of them having
had to leave russia are you in touch
with them
are there ways that we can help them
um
and i last but not least i believe it is
high time that we create this eu-wide
network of
opposition russian and russian-speaking
journalists in order to gather these
efforts of counteracting counteracting
kremlin propaganda both in russian
abroad and not only opposition
journalists maybe opposition journalists
is not the right it's not the proper way
because you know their journalists are
not with the power or with the
opposition but this broad platform with
gathered united efforts from the civil
society from journalists and from every
free voice as a matter of fact that
russia has in the diaspora so that we
can properly counter that and change
things there thank you very much
thank you very much for this
intervention and the questions
and before i switch to the questions of
the members of our committee i would
like to welcome
a visitors group hoyte hamvia
today we have visitors
they've been invited by hannes heider
this is a group of teachers
who are from vel's in austria
at a vocational school
rotational schools in austria and
germany part of the so-called dual
training system we have
practical and academic
i'm